-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm Padma Lakshmi.
And we are about --
Thank you!
[ Applause ]
We are about to play
a fun new game
called Cake Flip.
-♪ Caaake flip ♪
♪ Ca-a-ake fli-ip, yeah ♪
-Here's how it works.
We have two teams with
James, Kirk, and Jimmy
taking on Tariq, Mark,
and Quest.
-Alright, alright.
-Each player will have
30 seconds
to flip a cake, catch it,
and then decorate it.
When you hear the ding,
your time is up, gentlemen.
We'll do three rounds,
and at the end,
the audience will vote
for their favorite.
It's time for Round 1.
Tariq and James,
you're up first.
Best of luck to both of you.
When I say go,
you have 30 seconds
to flip your cakes
and then decorate the edges
and the sides.
Are you ready?
-No!
-Do you have it?
-James, come on, bud!
-Ready, set, go!
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-That is so good!
-Make it look nice.
-There you go, there you go.
-Yes, keep going. Keep going!
Oh, those roses are beautiful.
[ Applause ]
You have 8 seconds left.
-Some of these aren't working.
-7, 6, 5...
4, 3, 2, 1...
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright. Well done.
-I feel like we're in
the advantage right now.
Tariq kind of went
a little easy.
-Don't jinx it.
-Did I though?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-No, this is good.
-This is looking good.
-Alright, are we ready
for Round 2?
-Yes.
-Alright.
-Kirk, you got this, bud.
-Oh, God.
-Okay, Kirk and Mark.
When I say "go,"
or when I -- pbbt, you know.
-Mark doesn't even know
how to --
-You have 30 seconds to
flip your cakes
and then decorate the top.
Got it?
-Got it.
-Alright, okay.
Ready, set, go!
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Decorate the cake!
-No, that one's broken! Sorry.
Use this! Use this stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Momofu-who?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm making a hot dog.
-What?
[ Applause ]
-Soft hands, soft hands.
-7, 6, 5, 4...
3, 2, 1...
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is that? What is that?
-I...
-Is that a hot dog?
-It may be a hot dog.
It's an electric hot dog.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
If that's what you...
-Alright, ladies and gentlemen.
-We're already at
a disadvantage.
-We're ready for our third.
-How do I...
How do I...
-You guys have talked about
hot dogs before!
-The heck is going...
Certain adult stores
sell these cakes
in New York City.
-This is a family show.
-It's a family show.
-Alright, we are ready for
our third and final --
-Wait. Quest.
I think we gotta double flip it.
[ Crowd exclaims ]
-Say what?
-He talkin' about a --
-I'm talking about
a Greg Louganis.
-Remember, you have to
decorate your cakes.
Final round,
and Jimmy and Questlove,
you're up.
-How high can you flip?
Bonus points for how high.
-Grab your cakes.
-I have to double flip?
-Wait, wait, wait.
Not only do you have to flip it,
you have to write a message
to me.
And don't phone it in with
an XO, either.
Just saying. I'm just saying.
Alright? Ready?
-An XO? Better than what --
-Go!
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ahhh!
Look at it!
-Keep going!
-Do it!
♪♪
-Ahh!
[ Laughter ]
-There you go, there you go!
There you go!
-7, 6, 5, 4....
3, 2, 1...
[ Whistle blows ]
-There you go!
There you go!
-Alright, now it's time to see
which one came out the best.
-Look at, look at, look it.
Look at what he did.
What the hell is that?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-What is that?
-The metal tip is still in here.
That's a little bonus.
-Okay.
Okay, audience,
by round of applause,
do you like Team Jimmy's cake?
[ Applause ]
Or Team Questlove's cake?
[ Louder applause ]
Alright.
I think we have a winner.
It is Team Questlove!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ahh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Get back! Back!
-No!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
♪♪
-A heavy weapon.
-That's all the time we have
for Cake Flip.
My thanks to The Roots
for playing,
Padma for hosting.
[ Laughter ]
We'll be right back.
We'll be right back,
9:00 PM on Bravo.
We'll be right back.
Come on back.